-Hey, Kiki, how are you?
-I'm good, how are you?
-I'm doing very well.
I know you're based in
Los Angeles,
but is it true that
you made your way home
to get through these
troubled times?
-Yes, I had to.
I spent the first two months
of quarantine by myself,
and then I think I got tired
of myself.
And so yeah, now I'm back here
in Cincinnati with family.
-And now, have you managed
to not get tired of family?
-You know, surprisingly we're
doing all right.
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
Good for you guys.
-I'm like, we ain't
hanging in there.
I think it's because
they're feeding me.
So I'm like, as long as I get
free meals, I'm good.
-And how has --
you know, obviously,
usually for a big movie
like this, you would be
traveling around and doing
a lot of press.
Do you enjoy doing
a press junket from home?
-Um, yeah. I mean,
it has its benefits.
It's pretty cool just,
you know, being able
to be at home doing this.
But I don't know, I miss
some of the, you know, glam.
[ Laughter ]
Some of the glam moments
have been a little
hard to let go of.
But other than that, I'm like,
"This is pretty cool.
We can keep doing this."
-Yeah.
I imagine your family doesn't
lay out a nice thing
of croissants for you
every morning.
-Right, exactly. Maybe I should
ask them to do that.
-Yeah.
"The Old Guard" is such
a fun movie.
It's based on a comic book
that I read and loved.
Greg Rucka who wrote it
wrote the screenplay.
Did you know anything about this
comic going into it?
-No, I didn't know anything
about the comic until, you know,
I had started the
audition process.
So that was my first
introduction to it.
But I mean, once I read it,
I'm just like,
"Yo, this is dope. How do I get
to be a part of this?"
-And you got to work
with one of -- for my money
one of the dopest action stars
around right now,
Charlize Theron.
Did you -- I mean, I know she's
been injured a lot
doing stunts in her own films.
How did you hold up over the
course of the film
with a good amount
of fighting?
-Um, I held up pretty well.
You know, I didn't get any,
I don't know, injuries
that would make me not want
to do it again.
Just a few bumps and bruises.
Which, I mean,
Charlize was actually
really helpful in giving me
some pointers in terms of
how to help heal
and take care of.
And you know, any bumps
and bruises that were
a direct result of her,
I got some alcohol out of it,
some tequila, so.
-Oh, so if Charlize
accidentally kicks you
or something, you'd get a bottle
of alcohol?
-Yeah, yeah.
So that, which I learned.
I guess, I don't know if that's
like an action movie
kind of tradition, but
we were training, actually,
and she was wearing
her character boots
for the first time.
-Yes.
-Threw a kick right at my shin.
[ Laughter ]
And out of that, I got me a very
nice sized bottle of tequila.
I was like, "Okay."
-See, I would think
the more tequila you guys drank,
the more injuries would happen,
but maybe that's --
[ Laughter ]
Maybe that's part of the plan.
-Right, I'm like,
maybe that's it.
A little true.